So basically, we say,
we have to put in place,
schematically,
transition devices must be put in place
energy everywhere,
it is possible
to reduce gas emissions as a result,
because we are facing a climate emergency
and that it will have impacts
major environmental issues.
Okay,
the major environmental impacts there,
that we try to avoid by resorting to transition
energy,
using all metals
and mineral raw materials to feed
this transition plan,
the impacts should probably
exceed those we were trying to avoid
with its famous devices.
Yes,
but the baby seals,
they will always have ice
ha ha ha ha ha.
Yes yes,
so I'll tell you something
something I'm not sure about
but I can feel it coming,
the hunterétal gave me reason ha ha.
If we follow the transition plans,
transition and the,
the metallic demands that it represents,
and well,
I think that indeed
there will be more than penguins,
as 1 roughly healthy place to live,
here,
without wanting to exaggerate too much.
So there you go,
so that's why.
And so after,
indeed,
you mentioned 1,
1,
1 important point is the question of efforts.
So the question of efforts,
uh,
already compared to the afternoon,
there will never be enough effort,
since in fact it is about pollution that are
queens, uh,
contrary to what some say,
it's 1 loss.
Null,
it's a systematic loss of biodiversity,
right.
There are some
and certain people who claim,
in particular, that
that we could
have 1 renewed biodiversity after mining activity.
Here, there's typon, hettal,
two thousand and eleven,
yaghoul of two thousand and eleven,
I think it's two thousand and fourteen.
Well,
there are 1 lot of researchers
which explains that this is absolutely not true,
it is always 1 loss of biodiversity
after mining activity,
it is useless to seek biodiversity gain
after 1 ticket site.
In short,
so it's 1 loss,
and we will not return to the original state,
we will not return to the initial state,
it is impossible,
1 time we have that in mind,
of the blow,
it is necessary to think that
it's not a question of making an effort,
it's a question of responsibility.
Mining exploration should be.
This is not the case
today.
In any case,
that's not how rights are thought,
this is not how the
the operation of thousands of sites,
spend thousands of sites operating.
But the French state,
not the French state.
And the other states in fact,
should thwart this by forcing it,
considering
in fact that it is the responsibility of the operator.
Until the end of the end,
he is the one who extracted his materials,
so he is the one.
If we impose this on him,
no one will want to make holes anymore.
Ah well,
it's going to be complicated,
yes,
it will decrease greatly.
The interest
of the global warming eye that threatens us.
Well,
I can hear about global warming,
but listen. Uh.
As I told you with the example of a standard zoner,
uh earlier,
uh.
I'd like to know how we're going to do it.
To live in a holier environment
if we reduce the
greenhouse gas emissions,
if in parallel we develop the mining activity,
that's it you're not going to get
you will have some.
Consequences to.